so you're using making the films as a
launching pad for acting is this
something that you want to do as a
full-time career or you're still
interested in practicing medicine and
you know staying with helping your
patient and doing what I do I'm very
much interested in medicine and I will
always be interested in in helping my
patients so that's part of me that I
signed up for when I took the
Hippocratic oath so that I won't leave
behind but I also interested in being a
full-time actor so a lot of time people
get confused when you tell them like
well how can you be a professional in
one field and then want to do acting
like they will they'll say okay you're a
doctor but you want to be an actor but
you can be a professional in two
different careers it's very possible
it's it's just what's called time
management that's all it boils down to
so i very much am pursuing a full-time
career in acting but I'm not leaving
medicine behind I I all still in some
form run my practice and even be very
involved in that aspect and I and I and
I and I certainly believe I can do do
both you know I looked at you know
people's schedules actors schedules how
they work and you know the seasonal
approach they take and then the ship
send this in that and so I think it's
very doable since a lot of acting is
waiting for a role or an audition or
call back so it seems definitely doable
you mentioned to me earlier that you've
been interested in medicine since you
were in your teens what about acting
that too actually I was interested in
acting as a teenager but I've vols been
a very practical thinker so here I am
growing up in Seattle Washington in the
Pacific Northwest and you send yourself
and it'd be it'd be cool to be an actor
and I really really like movies and I
really like fantasy and its really
compelling to be someone that you are
not and that's the crux of being an
actor you
to live someone else's life and you find
that very compelling but then you come
back to and you're like wait a minute
i'm in seattle washington you know and I
don't know anybody and so you know as a
practical thinker I'm like well that's
never gonna happen I'm you know I
there's just no way what am I gonna do
as a fifteen-year-old just run off to
you know Hollywood give it a shot so and
I knew if even if I did that nothing was
going to become of it so I just put it
aside I said you know what I also really
very much interest in science and I'm
very much interested in medicine and
that aspect of you know helping people
and I think that's really cool so I just
went full bore into medicine i really
put all my heart into it and from the
time that i started medical school to
the time that i finished my residency
program I didn't think of anything else
I mean acting didn't even come in my
brain for eight years it was amazing I
was so focused on trying to be the best
physician I could be so I I really put
my heart my soul into it you know
studying doing what I could to to be a
good doctor but it's interesting though
because I ended up in Los Angeles
because of the choices I made and the
residency program I decided to go with
so i went from Washington to New Orleans
to medical school and then I got
accepted to the USC program for
dermatology and dermatological surgery
because I was top of my list because
they're very hands-on with skin cancer
and I wanted to be a skin cancer surgeon
so I'd applied to USC and I was hoping
to get in and I got in and so now here
I'm in LA and and it's still I'm not
thinking of acting i'm still in my
residency and i'm focused on that and
then in 2004 i'm done so and i started
working i'm done my residency and i have
time my mind opens up and I'm like okay
well I'm a medical drag I'm the medical
degree I'm board certified I started my
practice I'm
I'm doing good 2005 comes and I'm like
wait a minute then I I'm allowed to
think again in a sense I'm allowed to
think creatively looking looking at the
big picture just looking at life in
general and those feelings of wanting to
do something different something more
art something artistic in a different
form because I think practice of
medicine is very artistic especially
when you're doing skin cancer surgery
there's a there's an art to it I believe
but a different form of art acting and
it came back to me and I'm like waiting
I'm sitting here in LA now so being a
practical guy I think I can do this but
I'm the one who's going to have to call
the shots because I have gainful
employment I'm a professional and and I
and I believe in the code of being a
professional I can't go to the parties I
can't go to the west side and hang out
at coffee shops can't go out on Saturday
nights and you know be at the right
places and meet the right people so how
do i create a reality where this is
going to be doable I need to make a film
so that's when the journey started and I
and I started researching like how do
you make a film is it possible to make a
film can you act in your own film and so
that that started my journey to starting
the screenplay for awkward decision
which was in 2007 and then moving
forward
you